all right i think this guy's about to be
a new favorite uh his name is
confidence chris oh boy sounds like a
life coach or some [ __ ] he's not you
ever been told you look like
you have been told like hi
what you ever been told you look like
chris's
wife chris's wife i don't know my name
is chris oh yeah what's your name
yeah what's your name hannah what you're
doing is christmas what the [ __ ] do you
think she's doing she's hiking [ __ ]
what does that look like uh like an open
heart surgery what are you doing i'm i'm
man ugh
confidence crisp
lack of self-awareness chris hey man
let's find out where this is coming out
with corny ass uh
court coming out with courtney ass
[ __ ] pickup lines yo if you was a
pirate
if you yo yo if you was a pirate
like would you have your pirate here
or there
there's just something also funny about
approaching somebody on a hiking trail
that screams like you want to get
dragged into a bush and break forget
about that this is something like i
guess i'm all for shooting your shot no
but just like know the place as well you
know what i mean if she walking through
a back alley don't be like hey uh it's
kind of dark and nice
it's kind of kind of dark in here huh
oh it's dangerous isn't it
like everything is [ __ ] yo what's up
girl yeah yeah yeah yeah you like dark
yeah chocolate hey like
yeah sits back catch a girl walking home
at 1 am empty ass street just pop up
behind her excuse me miss
where you going
and i don't want [ __ ] to
approach me when i looked like this
what'd you say
like the sun in my face it's all hot and
[ __ ] man get the [ __ ] out
and you feel me
but he's doing it with the spy glasses
so they don't know he's filming oh wow
yeah
yeah yeah so these people are growing up
on these platforms and didn't ask to be
part of this [ __ ] whatsoever hey hey hey
you you look like chris's wife
who chris's wife
who's that i'm chris
oh that's cute yeah yeah where are you
where are you going
there's a bush over there
let's see where it goes we made some
research today to know what chris does
in the confine of is hiking
study some work
yeah it is yes the african deer sport
does not claim you nice to meet you how
are you doing good that's good that's
good you
what brings you out here
i came to meet chris what the [ __ ] you
think i'm doing
i was pandexing [ __ ] with my running
shoes i'm hiking dum-dum hiking
yeah you like hiking yeah this is like
my first time here what do you think of
it
i come here all the time hey he's having
a conversation so you know what i did
all that while [ __ ] and i said all them
things but hey you talking to her so
do you do
do you think chris put
hey listen let me just tell you
sometimes people who are just being nice
will stay in a conversation they
desperately want to exit yes well the
body language doesn't exist yeah because
because she's talking about she's like
this she's like this huh yeah
yeah
it was me
the moment i realized something weird
happened i just walk away i won't even
look
hey my name is
microsoft
do i phone you now or later
you don't do
before we go in with this [ __ ] my girl
you're standing like a girl that in in
middle school grew boobies too much and
try to hide them so her posture was the
whole like that
that that posture was [ __ ] up my girl
that posture was crazy
that posture was i don't even know how
your arms are so under your heart like
this is crazy miguel
like a whole turtle girl oh damn that's
[ __ ] up yo [ __ ] i don't know what's
going on with your wardrobe but you
blending into that background this is a
very weird part of placement he's trying
to fit between them two phones that's
right bro it looks like an optical
illusion yeah this is [ __ ] me up yeah
and anybody wants that oh this is fake
trust me those rejections were 150
percent real no no no no i took one look
at those women's faces and i knew they
were really saying no i'm not staged
tough
who thinks so [ __ ]
this posture okay hold on you can't even
write it are we filmed yeah yeah
it's like nobody does that
nobody does that if they know they do
that
they don't
that's what it was like
imagine imagine we say some [ __ ] and
give the posture you choose
imagine we say some [ __ ] and you decide
oh wait wait
let me get the best of me hey
imagine that's what they want that's
[ __ ] up no that's not staged anyways
oh that posture still triggered the
that is probably the part of this whole
video that triggers me the most i'm not
i was i was my back was hurting watching
that [ __ ] i'm like how are you
comfortable
how are you comfortable my
how are you even oh yeah this
i'm not even going for i'm not perfectly
fine
i'm not going to go front y'all that's
grounds to break up with somebody oh man
i refuse to take a girl out anywhere who
stands around like nah b you imagine hey
guys this is my girlfriend sandra
hey
like the posture scream i hate myself so
why should you like me like
yo i have a god damn that posture
[ __ ]
my nightmare yeah
no that was kind of funny to be honest
really
wow you have no sense of humor it really
wasn't funny meanwhile her girlfriend's
dying
it was not funny
the girl is that she's she's
bent in half
you know what i like about chris he
laughs at himself he says this is not
how you treat a king
how you doing
you're like the prettiest girl i've seen
today
i think
yeah you're like the prettiest girl i've
seen today
i think
because you already know when he was
rehearsing this he's like all right
i'm i'm gonna compliment her and just
[ __ ] at the end i got this i
i i
you the freshest [ __ ] i see
today
past six hours
because seven hours ago god damn
girl got a
donkey on her let's go let's switch it
with your left hand you're not supposed
to do that what the left-hand shape
all right he knows he ain't got that
much confidence right and he does this
[ __ ] on purpose so that guy i think
who's there you got to go out to the
ladies talk to them to actually gain
that confidence yes and confidence isn't
doesn't mean that you're skillful
it just means that you gotta do it yeah
you're gonna do it
so he could he does seem to have that
confidence maybe he just doesn't have
anything else you know how they say half
the fight is showing up yeah he showed
up and didn't do anything else
well let's take the point he said i have
the fight showing up i did my half
we here then
you know when you take a test and it
just takes 50 to pass
[ __ ] just showed up
yeah
i shut up
no he's a troll
no no no he's a troll he's a troll that
though he okay what confidence i get it
guys dude's a genius [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it dude's a genius
do the genius it's okay you know what i
misjudged you i don't know
i don't think i've seen anybody say are
you in line and then go further into the
line in front of them i mean if you
would ask me are you in line and then
you go to the person in front of you
it's like [ __ ] i told you i'm playing
behind him that guy that guy's a genius
cause he wants people to have like it's
reaction and you saw how the reaction
was strong to say [ __ ] you you
you won just like seeing a man and a
woman holding hands you be like hey hey
hey man you y'all a couple yeah hey
woman
y'all a couple yeah
okay cool
what y'all doing
hey are you
are y'all in line yeah
crazy yeah yeah are you all in that yeah
are you are you eyeliner yeah
are you are
y'all in line yeah so this
motherfucker's a huge stroke
congratulations chris
you you got me you got me
you got me yes okay
hey uh you're a babe i was just thinking
like i'm gonna eat them digits i think
i mean you need them ditches
not the dishes
yeah hey hey hey you wanna die i'm gonna
need the dishes done [ __ ] get back in
the game get i was like what the [ __ ]
did he say digits digits all right cool
that's how i know this is real
because that interaction right there is
so [ __ ] real that's how ninety
percent of approaches go
[ __ ] coming up behind a girl be
like hey what up i look no i'm good
i think he's a used troll i think that's
part of like the confidence routine he
probably built was like just go up to
people and be absurd and be comfortable
being absurd congratulations yeah hey i
just got here but i just thought you
were like so cute i just wanted to tell
you thank you yeah what's your name kai
like get to know yourself no oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you walk away you know what i mean i
don't care if you go ah [ __ ]
me [ __ ] like i don't care what you say
after you take it out i respect i
understand so i'm not mad at you
cruz showed up hey you just needed 50 to
pass hey man shout out to chris he's an
equal opportunist [ __ ] could i have a
posture like hunchback a notre dame
and he'd be like
so microsoft
for all those who find this weird like
why would you go to people and do all
this stuff you know at the end of the
day people don't like meeting at the
club okay they don't like meeting on
dating apps nowadays because they're
going to go to eating episode naturals
so people approach in person
now is it the smoothest way of doing it
no but what's the harm just coming up
shooting this shot the girl says no walk
away i wouldn't do it but hey maybe i'm
missing it so y'all can let me know in
the comments and you wouldn't do what no
i'll approach people live and just talk
to them like on that tip how would you
meet people i don't i don't know okay so
you can
i know i don't know what i would do
exactly but
no let me rephrase actually let me
rephrase it
walking up to a [ __ ] is
terrifying
true uh yeah i understand that it's
[ __ ]
it's it's horrible
terrifying to walk up to a girl and what
nah man i don't think i would do it i
nah i wouldn't do it
i don't think i you wouldn't do it
until you feel like you need to do it in
order to meet somebody you get what
you're trying to say yeah
so i grew up in the area before a lot of
the online dating stuff when i once come
through like
my space was a thing you know i mean
plenty of fish had just started but
people were not online like that
so you have to go to meet people yeah
right
and so
here's something else that's real
trying to meet women at night clubs was
way harder than trying to meet people
during the day
really
guards were up also there's a lot of
competitions a lot of other dudes there
trying to meet women so
you know during the day it's a little
bit different it feels a little less
clubby and dirty raunchy so you just go
up to people and you talk to them it
could end up going well now of course
you got to find the limit of like don't
be too pushy or anything like that but
um i grew up in that era so
before i had dance before i had hobbies
before i had a lot of activities that
made me meet people more naturally and
like through events
that was the only way to meet people
you know what i'm saying and so you know
if you're if you're lonely that's right
enough yeah you go you go start
approaching people and it's scary until
you start doing it and realize like okay
the fear is really in the mind of being
rejected but once you get past that what
whatever you say if you're lonely and
desperate enough it really sounds like
hey
men are like that yeah women women that
are desperate too
yeah
they they they don't they'll act
together so yeah that's just one of
those things but
maybe you guys feel differently maybe
you guys have a different take or
opinion we want to hear from you in the
comments below let us know